all right
i know that
some people don't like that i am taking
such pleasure
in the failures of donald trump's social
media platform truth social
essential but i am taking significant
pleasure in what appears to be its
imminent failure
there is yet
another obstacle now for donald trump's
truth social
it has been barred from google play
over content moderation issues this is
an article from the hill
content moderation concerns
are holding up the approval of former
president trump's truth social app on
android devices
according to a google spokesperson
truth social ceo devin nunes
claimed last week that the android
version was ready and waiting
however a google spokesperson said that
the platform lacks effective content
moderation needed to meet the google
play app store's terms of service the
spokesperson said quote on august 19 we
notified truth social of several
violations
of standard policies in their current
app submission and reiterated having
effective systems for moderating user
generated content is a condition of our
terms of service for any app
to go live on google play
they don't actually have the proper
content moderation so this this is so
funny because
first of all they brand themselves as a
free speech app
saying conservatives are being silenced
there is such demand for a real free
speech app turns out
conservatives weren't that eager to get
on truth social and it also turns out it
wasn't really a free speech app if you
would go on truth social and you would
talk about the january 6th hearings you
would get banned if you made negative
comments about trump to some degree you
would get banned we started seeing all
these different things
but at the same time
the little content moderation that there
is
isn't even enough to meet the standards
required to be on the google play store
which is like the i i the um i don't
have an apple it's the i store the
iphone
itunes store i guess it's called
um
and it is just every every aspect of
this is delightful so my expectation is
very soon
truth social will be done
it might remain up to make it appear as
though it's not really done but they've
stopped paying vendors and owe their web
hosting company 1.6 million dollars as
of about a week ago uh
there's almost no interaction on the
platform as a as a goof for a little
while i was posting on it but about a
week ago i stopped because it became
clear there's just no point it's a dead
sight even trump sometimes only gets a
couple thousand interactions to his
posts and the best part about all of
this is
they're failing on their own no nobody's
censoring them
they
are just not attracting people
and it's all flailing it's all pathetic
it's all hilarious and i love absolutely
every second of it we are going to be
off on monday for the federal labor day
holiday and then we're going to be back
really through the election quite
frankly um there's columbus day coming
up but beyond that we're going to be
here through the election we are going
to be covering debates we will be
covering election results we will be
covering covering rallies and so many
other things
and i'm so glad to have everybody with
us and we're soon going to have more
news about the launch of the new youtube
channel and so many other different
things of course you can always sign up
at
joinpacman.com
alex jones finds it predatory that is a
freaking predator right there but
members love it members love the bonus
show they love all of it and i encourage
you to sign up at joinpakman.com you can
use the coupon code
big
voting22 get yourselves a discount and
we will be back right after this
extraordinarily short break
one of our sponsors today is bluechu a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping